animal shelters across the United States  have started teaching their cats to give  high-fives to make them more adoptable  this is a true thing it's happening  they're teaching them it's got to true  story true story they found that people  are much more likely to adopt a cat that  knows how to high-five that's true yeah  as a result people have already been  adopting the cats in record numbers  here's some footage of the new cat  owners it's pretty cool take a look yes  thank you so much I'll see you Monday I  got the job hey I'm almost done that's  what she said  [Laughter]  we're still going  feel if you can just grab a still of the  cat high-fiving the dog that is the  [Applause]  that's the worst damn puppeteering you  will ever see that's just that's just a  bottle brush to be audiio honest with  our audience that's that wasn't good  you